des protections qui ne cache pas la
bouche voilà que les malentendants
peuvent à nouveau lire sur les lèvres
les masques classique c'est pour ajouter
un handicap au handicap
un de plus dans une société qui a
toujours eu du mal à leur faire une
juste place
les changes peut alors commencer premier
écueil l'accès au travail malgré une loi
de 1975 qui oblige les entreprises à
embaucher des personnes handicapées pour
les sourds trouver un emploi reste
compliqué en témoignent ces jeunes en
normal le déficit là ça va décoller des
patrons
sont pas tellement d'accord avec lui
pour le directeur de ce centre toujours
en 1983 c'est la société entière qui
exclut les sourds
le gros problème sans même donner
d'informations sur la sur la surdité qui
commence avec les parents mais qui vint
jusqu aux employeurs et qui se poursuit
toulousain vie et ce dès l'enfance pour
les sourds l'apprentissage de la langue
des signes est longtemps restée
marginale en france jusque dans les
années 90 c'est laura lisation c'est à
dire la tentative de parole qui était
privilégiée dans cette école primaire en
1992 parents et associations ont dû se
battre pour obtenir des cours pour les
enfants sourds on a pendant deux ans
chercher des sponsors pour
que la langue des signes
et lieu à l'école marceau il ya des
enfants souffrent qu'ils peuvent pas
peuvent pas oralisée donc ils ont que la
langue des signes emploi écoles mais
aussi tous les domaines de la vie
publique
rares sont les manifestations des
personnes sourdes mais en 1995 année
présidentielle
ils descendent dans les rues de tout le
pays ils s'estiment lésés par la
campagne à quatre jours de l'élection
les sourds et les malentendants ont
manifesté nombreux aujourd'hui dans la
capitale à bordeaux également une
centaine de personnes ont défilé et
brûlé leur carte d'électeur au quotidien
les personnes sourdes souffre du manque
de communication avec les entendants
surtout dans les administrations et dans
les milieux médicaux
c'est ce que dénonce cette guide
interprète en 2003 lorsqu'un patient
souffre arrive y'a personne n'y a
personne comme on communique avec lui
il comprend pas alors on va essayer
d'articuler on va essayer d'écrire un
petit peu où on va donner qu'un petit
peu d'explications vous rendez compte le
stress qui peut avoir encore faut-il que
la langue des signes soient plus
largement pratiqué chez les déficients
auditifs
parmi les 300 milles sourds en france
entre 80000 et 120 milles pratiquer la
langue des signes
[Musique]